Bienvenidos a nuestra Crónica de
economía de fin de semana para ello
Contamos con nuestra compañera Daniela
Blandón Daniela bienvenida Muchas
gracias Rodrigo Bueno vamos a empezar
hablando de economía en Bolivia Porque
algo está pasando allí con los dólares
así después este país se enfrenta una
escasez de la divisa que muestra apenas
una leve mirada los problemas económicos
que hay de fondo todo comenzó en
marzo de ayuda de las reservas de
dólares en el Banco Central esto causó
temor en la población y generó una
sobredemanda de dólares que el banco
todavía intenta sortear con varias
medidas Como por ejemplo comprárselos a
un precio especial a los exportadores el
gobierno culpó a los especuladores y lo
atribuyó a noticias falsas Lo cierto es
que esto aumentó la incertidumbre sobre
la economía que por décadas ha sido
llamada El Milagro económico gracias a
recortes de exportaciones de
hidrocarburos tras la nacionalización de
ese sector en 2006 y también con un
crecimiento sostenido del producto
interno bruto y una inflación
relativamente baja pero Bolivia descuidó
su producto estrella desde 2015 las
reservas de gas comenzaron a bajar al
igual que las ventas al extranjero Y en
lugar de intervenir el gobierno comenzó
a comerse todos sus ahorros así lo
explica Gonzalo Chávez economista de la
Universidad Católica boliviana
pero a partir del
2014-2015 caen de manera significativa
los ingresos por exportaciones porque
los precios de las materias primas gas
minerales y soya también bajan
significativamente y hacen que el país
reduzca el total de sus exportaciones a
8.700 millones de dos
y no se hace un ajuste de gastos e
ingresos en ese momento el gobierno
sigue gastando como si no hubiera habido
el choque externo pero resulta que
utilizamos deuda interna deuda externa y
pérdida de reservas internacionales para
justamente atenuar el choque externo las
reservas internacionales en el año 2014
habían sido quince mil millones de
dólares Entonces es a partir de este
momento que el gobierno para tanto
preinversión como para gasto comienza a
utilizar las reservas internacionales
durante el gobierno de Evo Morales se
gastaron aproximadamente ocho mil
cincuenta millones de dólares Durante
los gobiernos de añes y Arce
aproximadamente otros tres mil millones
de dólares bueno Dani Entonces por lo
que cuentas tú y nos cuenta nuestro
experto esta crisis tiene sus raíces en
los gobiernos anteriores Pues
básicamente con esa reserva los
gobiernos de Evo Morales Yanina añez y
Luis Arce han mantenido generosos
programas sociales por ejemplo el
subsidio de la compra de combustible
antes Bolivia exportaba hidrocarburos y
ahora los compra pagando a precios
internacionales de cada litro de
gasolina importado para que se hagan una
idea el consumidor final solamente paga
la mitad ahora las reservas
internacionales como lo decía el
invitado rondaban los 15.500 millones de
dólares en 2014 ahora cayeron a un
mínimo histórico también el riesgo país
se vio afectado el ranking está
vinculado al precio de los bonos
soberanos que también había caído a
mínimos en dos días solamente este
indicador cayó 600 puntos y se ubicó
entre los países con más riesgo de la
región Pero cuál es el verdadero impacto
nos lo explica nuestro invitado el
cambio en las expectativas y en la
reputación del modelo económico No si
entonces a partir del problema de las
Divisas que comienzan a aparecer este
síntomas y problemas que ya se venían
reflejando hace mucho tiempo no De hecho
calificadores de riesgo internacionales
revistas internacionales el propio
mercado privado este comienza a ver eso
y bajan los indicadores internacionales
para el caso boliviano no
Por supuesto que esto genera pues una
incertidumbre muy grande entre las entre
las personas y un poco retarda todo el
aparato productivo porque al haber pocos
dólares se retrasan importaciones se
vuelve más lenta se vuelve más caras se
que se genera por primera vez en muchos
años en Bolivia una especie de Mercado
paralelo No es cierto que es ilegal por
supuesto pero aparece este y sobre todo
va mostrando que detrás de esta escasez
de Divisas lo que teníamos es serios
problemas Fiscales nueve años de déficit
público tenemos problemas complejos con
la reducción del tamaño del sector
exportador boliviano de hidrocarburos y
Dani ahora me gustaría saber qué está
haciendo el gobierno para contener esta
crisis pues tras admitir dificultades
económicas el presidente Luis Arce
promovió la aprobación de la llamada ley
del Oro para fortalecer las reservas
Internacionales La iniciativa ya fue
aprobada en la cámara de diputados
Bueno lo que el gobierno está queriendo
hacer A través del Banco Central es
recomponer lo más rápido posible las
reservas internacionales para eso ha
hecho el uso de los Derechos especiales
de giro como a cuatrocientos millones de
dólares que seguramente ya estos días ya
han sido utilizados este está queriendo
la aprobación de una ley del Oro de
compra y venta del oro en el congreso
boliviano y esto ya pasó en diputados
fue aprobada
y probablemente también va a ser
aceptado y la idea es que como Bolivia
tiene alrededor de tres mil millones de
dólares todavía de reservas
internacionales parte de esto está en
oro este y ese oro necesita de una
aprobación congresal para ser vendido y
en esta primera etapa en diputados ya
han autorizado la venta de la mitad de
este Oro son como cuarenta y tres
toneladas que a los precios del Oro de
hoy sería n como dos mil seiscientos
millones de dólares por lo tanto el
gobierno quiere acceder para seguir su
financiamiento estos mil trescientos
millones de dólares bueno Daniela Muchas
gracias por esta completa Crónica de fin
de semana sobre Bolivia aquí nos vemos
en una próxima ocasión Seguiremos
Daniela Muchas gracias a nuestros
espectadores les invitamos a que sigan
en France 24
[Música]